joining me today is a student and
activist and the director of high school
outreach for turning-point USA Calcasieu
welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me on I am excited to have you
here we've met a couple times we've done
some events together you are seemingly
wise beyond your years
Thanks that's true yeah all right let's
get to it well actually I mean in a
weird way I guess you've been you've
been sort of thrust into being wise
behind your years you were obviously a
survivor of the Parkland shooting as you
know I had your classmate Chimeran
Caskey I'm a couple weeks ago and he
kind of laid out what happened to him
that day and subsequently everything
that's happened so let's just start
there because that's kind of what put
you on the map okay I'll sort of preface
it um I don't like her I don't like to
refer myself as a survivor because I
wasn't in the building that was shot
into and I think that you know cheapens
knee of pain and tragedy that people who
were in the building so what happened
with me that day I was fourth period I I
was in I was in my fourth period class
and all of a sudden the alarms ring so
we go into the hallway and we're walking
out and we hear two like two little pops
I don't know if two tech books fell you
know fire fire works I really had no
idea so we run back and I go and reach
for the other door to my classroom and
the the teacher locked it so you go into
a nearby room we get in there and we
just hide for two hours straight we just
hear pops and ambulances in the distance
so that was the freshman building and
the entire time we had no idea was going
on and then all throughout the entire
time people immediately are just
villainizing guns you know the second we
got a second I got out of the the closet
that I was in kids were like we have to
ban ar-15s
yeah well let's not jump into the
political part yes it's like because
it's interesting just listening to you
hear about that it's almost like the way
you were describing it almost sounds
like you weren't even there like it's
just like a story that you were telling
you know in a bizarre way so once okay
so all of this happens you find out now
there there are dead students I mean to
do a friend yes old and
so we get it up that we get out of the
closet so woth takes us out they put
their you know err 15s in our faces take
us out we have to put our hands on the
person in front of us walking outside
and all throughout this the most
disgusting thing was every single corner
of the entire block surrounding us was
just filled with media cars
it was just like jam-packed and what I
saw there was that whenever there was
like someone crying or like a moment of
pain the media would just surround them
and encapsulate them and I got home and
I was really hoping that this wouldn't
be like a politicized spectacle with
like mass you know media jumping the gun
to everything and sadly that was the
case so when I was like sitting there in
shock seeing the numbers rise on the
screens for the death count it was like
so insane to internalize like what had
just occurred because like everyone's
always you know this will never happened
to my school how could this happen to my
school and the sad reality is it can
happen to any school like I mean
stoneman's I wasn't the most affluent
low crime you know city I think in like
southern Florida and this happened at
our school did you know some of the kids
that were killed yeah I knew one girl
Helena she was in a class of my year
back yeah so what kind of time did you
guys have to grieve because that you're
already alluding to this but it was like
it was as if the event happened the
shooting happened and then it's
seemingly there was no grieving and then
you guys were all over the television
you were all over Twitter you had all
political people using you guys in all
sorts of different ways just tell me a
little bit about just kind of a grieving
and trying to be able to be how old you
know sanneh 10 you're 17 trying to be 16
15 16 17 year old kids trying to just
survive something unimaginably horrible
yeah I don't know how freshmen and
sophomores like have managed to go
through this like I'm at least in June I
was a junior at the time so I knew the
school a bit better and like somewhat of
my self esteems a little more build up
more and a little bit more mature but
there was absolutely like no time to
grieve or whatsoever like a few days
after the shooting there any buses up to
Tallahassee till you know kind of like
pushed like tugging the emotional
heartstrings of Republicans to pass
legislation that the otherwise wouldn't
have passed who's they in that equation
so there are some members in
Florida Senate that like personally like
coordinated buses from parkland to
Tallahassee yeah and what were your
parents saying or the friends you know
friends parents like it just seemed like
the parents were almost gone now there
are some of the parents that are a
little more high-profile that I that I
see but it was as if you guys were just
like taken that's what it felt like
suddenly we're seeing you on CNN in town
halls and I want to talk a little bit
about that but just like that you were
just used all over the place we're not
even having a moment to just digest what
happened so so here's how I don't think
that necessarily so so here's what I
think would happen I think that the kids
saw what happened they were shocked as
they should be and they decide attack
like we said this can't happen to anyone
else ever again let's do something you
know what really occurred is that the
mainstream media jumped jumped on this
immediately and just like put it to like
a national scale and and really used it
to push a gun control agenda and that's
why I started speaking out because I
wanted to represent the other side of
stone Douglass who doesn't believe in
gun control yeah so just tell me a
little bit about you in high school
before this jump the lie yeah yeah yeah
what was kiled could she like before
this because I know you sort of as a
political beast now and like a wickedly
incisive Twitterer and like you know
you've put on events that I've been part
of and I and you're incredibly organized
and connecting with great people and all
that stuff but just tell me about the
kid before that day I'll give you all
the recap yeah I'll give you the story
of my life life story let's yeah yeah so
so my parents came from Israel they
immigrated here my dad my mom served in
the IDF they came here has nothing
worked their way up and then when I was
when I was at home late Tommy Hebrew in
English so we only spoke Hebrew at home
so I'm fluent Hebrew and they put me
through school and I was always the
shortest kid in the grade so I was like
always like I was just like even shorter
than the shortest girl
am i great I was like super short and
like what was it like like eighth grade
I was four foot eight I was like legally
a [ __ ]
whoa in eighth grade so I got bullied a
lot like I try not to have a victimhood
mentality because I don't think it's
successful and I think you agree with me
on that absolutely so I was always
bullied and I was always extremely smart
so that kind of
back on me a little bit but I was always
bought a lot and it built up my
self-esteem in addition I was always
like taking the hardest classes my
parents would over push me to take the
hardest classes possible so it Douglas
before all this you know I someone had a
good social life so I would basically I
would go to school do my AP classes go
home play video games so like 10:10 p.m.
start homework to like start homework
you know and then finish it at 2:00 a.m.
and then have like 5 hours of sleep
because that was my cycle was terrible
yeah but I was like super addicted to
video games and then the shooting
happens and just turned my entire life
upside down so it just completely
changed me so at that moment you know I
had to become much more mature I had I
was living in the adult world you know I
had responsibilities or things I had to
do you know I had to act a proper
certain way and you know did you have
any particular political beliefs before
all this cuz you're definitely in terms
of at least the the kids or the young
people that are public about all of this
now that have come out of Stoneman
Douglas I mean you definitely are the
one that seemed at least that I know of
is is the furthest right that is sort of
embraced conservatism and all that did
is that where you were politically oh
here's the thing about me my parents
aren't political at all whatsoever so
all my political beliefs I've developed
myself and how I develop every single
political belief is just I look at it
straight from a rational logical point
of view with no emotions whatsoever I
think you can guess I'm not an emotional
person yeah so like I think with with
legislative decisions you have to put
emotion as far out of it as possible you
have to do policies that that actually
solved the problem not just make you
feel good so I'm really not not for like
feel-good policies yeah but did you care
about politics at all before any of this
or is this news yeah I did care the 2016
election I was I was somewhat into it
after the election I kind of didn't care
as much but I was always like somewhat
of a second Amendment supporter yeah but
when I when I started speaking out so
it's really interesting when I started
speaking out ah it was like a tidal wave
of opposition you know I had my schools
against me someone seemed like that you
know all my peers were against me and I
try not to do a victimhood talib it I
just want to paint
sure of how it actually was and then
seemed like the community that
mainstream me and my friends you know it
seems like I was going against every
single opposition you know I was scared
like this could this could ruin my life
but you know I believed in what I was
doing and I just powered through it and
just really I just stuck to my beliefs
in didn't let anyone tell me otherwise
because you know when I was so when I
was in Tallahassee when they were
pushing Republican legislators to enact
gun control legislation
I said look gun control isn't gonna
solve the problem I want to solve the
problem okay I want to make sure that
school school shootings never happened
what can I do to actually make that
happen and what can I do while
protecting the Second Amendment because
I actually believe it's one of those
fundamental rights of Americans so while
I was there I started speaking out and
nobody cared like I would go to
reporters and nobody cared so I had to
forcefully you know like talk to
reporters say hey look I'm a
conservative can I reach out and then I
managed to get Leland Vitter's a contact
with inveterate Fox
and I went on Fox in it in an interview
and then ben shapiro saw it and it blew
off but all the while that's the first
time I remember seeing yeah and all the
while there's this extreme opposition
and the entire thing that I've always
had
sorry wearing it well I just wanted to
what do you because I know you you kind
of mock the media the way I do now on
Twitter and just sort of what mainstream
media has become and that they're really
activists and not journalists and that
whole thing but were you shocked when
you were going up to them and going you
know I'm a conservative or I want to
defend the Second Amendment but I'm a
student from this school and they're
just blue blatantly ignoring you or even
I know this is minor but like I remember
when a bunch of you guys were all
verified on Twitter it was I was like
you worry yeah and it was Instagram as
well it took me like three months after
everyone else yeah and I'm not saying
that that it doesn't really mean it
doesn't matter in of itself
yeah it is it is a symptom of sort of
the broader situation going on here with
tech companies and media and all that
like were they flat-out
ignoring you like you saw them
interviewing people and then so here's
here's what occurred the main organizers
of that that you Sheila Cruz a solid
group of like the March for alive kids
yeah at this point they had solidified a
clique and they wouldn't let anyone new
or with a different opposing view into
it so I said I have to take matters into
my own hand in addition we're in
Tallahassee I realized that the
mainstream media is just doing this for
clicks because can we think about it
when mastering occurs the mainstream
media loves it like they get great
coverage they get great amount of views
they do I'll switch I'll talk to like
notoriety in addition after this but I
saw that when someone there was a girl
crying in Tallahassee and the second she
cried just she got sworn by reporters
and I thought they were just looking for
clicks and for headlines it and I
realized that they're really they're not
reading it for the right reasons they're
not gonna listen to a rational
irrational young kid like me okay yeah
so in addition I also realized that
there was an extreme amount of just
people were just getting benefiting off
of this so much so after the shooting we
realized that a lot of this occurred
because the shooter who I trying to say
his name ever because I think that gives
him to notarize matter they were they
they would they would post so here's
what time did so the video of the
shooter where basically says you know
I'm gonna be the next school shooter of
2018 I want twenty people and he
basically says you're all gonna see me
on the news so and then Time magazine
puts this video up on YouTube it gets
3.6 million views and the same thing
with all the other videos you know CNN
talked about this exact clip and
basically just still showed it on air
yeah so the entire thing what the
mainstream media is doing is that
they're basically they're just
benefiting off the situation and what
they don't realize is they're
perpetuating the issue and making it
worse that's why I think daily wire Ben
is doing a great decision with not
showing their names and faces because
it's an ethical decision yeah no I don't
think government should impose on you
know in the mainstream media to not
allow the show their faces but I think
it's an ethical and moral decision that
people should be taking up yeah so just
to be totally clear so after this
shooting that was when band announced
he's the editor yeah the 1980 wire they
are no longer gonna yet show their name
if they do doctor yeah so okay so you
started to see this this issue with the
media that they're ignoring people like
you and they're sort of making other
people's stars and they're going for the
cliques and all of that
what about you no I don't want to make
this about people per se but so that
that little clique of of kids that then
was all over the media and was getting
retweeted by every celebrity and all of
that were you trying to reach out to
them at all and just have that
discussion or was it just very clear
though yeah absolutely and I still try
to have that discussion you know when
they first started speaking out I said
oh my god that's great someone's
speaking out and originally when the
movement started speed wasn't started
you know remember Cameron kasky was on
the car shouting the movement wasn't an
anti-gun movement it was an anti school
shooting movement and I said hey guys
this is quickly I just I was like I gave
him a warning guys it looks like you're
moving to the direction of an anti-gun
movement and I don't think that's
beneficial at all so here's my point of
view I tried communicating and I and I
tried speaking and they really didn't
care in allowing me so I said okay I
have to go solo and that's what I've
been doing but I've always been open to
discussion and open debate I think I'm
some of the great things of our country
where you can have you know open
discussion and just free expression of
ideas that's why I think the Kayne thing
is somewhat great because regardless of
what you think of the person or
celebrity I'm not I'm not in favor of
propping up celebrities and their
political opinions simply because
they're famous but you don't need a lot
of political expertise to say that I
believe in free expression free thought
right that's that shouldn't be a really
controversial position to be to be
staking out all right so you mentioned
Cameron and you know I had him on the
show okay yeah thanks ago he's going
through a very interesting evolution
right now I suspect I can figure out
where this is gonna end up which
actually be much closer to your position
than the position that he's sort of at
right now because I just continually see
that as the evolution of things the more
that he understands rights and all of
those things but I was happy to hear his
thoughts and all that look he sat down
with me he sat down with Shapiro and I
think he'll continue to do that have you
guys been able to make any peace with
some of this or you must at least be
enjoying the fact that somebody's kind
of coming around you know I think I
think Kim's a good guy I think that what
we're seeing right now is that he's
matured I mean we've all made so Mimi
and cam have gone through like the same
political slash media you know
experience so we can understand each
other
what happened with cam is like look
we've all made mistakes we've
all said stuff we don't want to but he's
matured and I've also matured and what I
see what I think is happening with cam
it's a natural progression of just
having logical thought instead of
emotions and I think logic and facts
moves you towards the political beliefs
of being a conservative okay so all of
this happens I think the the sort of
rock bottom of this was that CNN Town
Hall I was terrible
yeah just share your thoughts on that so
here's what happened with the scene in
Town Hall so a lot of the kids that you
saw there were actually flown in a
private jet from Tallahassee so already
at the time of the Town Hall there was a
solidified group click of the kids that
you see now and they won't let anything
in so they actually flew these kids on a
private jet from Tallahassee to the Town
Hall and right there it was it was just
simply they were just it was an anti-gun
debate and they were just villainizing
Rubio and Dana lash for things that had
nothing into their control whatsoever it
wasn't their fault and Marco Rubio was
villainized to such an extreme extent
and he's one of the best senators so
you've now connected with Rubio
yeah yeah I mean I hate it because when
people say that politicians just don't
care it's just so wrong I mean
politicians they do care and you know he
was one of the greatest supporters of
the stops go violence act that we got
past you just help push it and look
these senators don't want this to occur
Kenney one and just saying that
politicians want this to happen is just
wrong do you have any thoughts on what
actually happened that day in terms of
security or what should have happened or
should have it shouldn't have happened
because even now when you go back and
listen depending on where you're getting
your news from this it sounds you know
they either stepped down or they didn't
go in or this or that or the other thing
and it's like well well what what should
have happened in the ideal world that
that you want to create in the system
that you want to create to protect this
these schools from not having this
happen again what what should happen
that day what we saw my school was
simply and utterly just massive
incompetence and a failure of law
enforcement
so the shooter was flagged multiple
times by the school by the school
administration they knew he had mental
issues he was put into the promise
program and they knew that this kid was
a threat there were 76 times the police
there were 76 times the police came to
his house there were two FBI reports
they knew that this kid was a threat and
the law enforcement was completely
incompetent at that level and they
didn't do absolutely anything
everyone knew this kid was an issue what
happened at school was was just utter
incompetence in addition so when he gets
on campus okay he just makes a straight
beeline for the freshman building and at
the exact same time we had a school
resource officer who heard the gunfire
and came and he just hid in a corner
while kids were dying and then three
unarmed individuals rushed to save it
three are three unarmed went to the
building and died trying to save kids
what we should have had and this is why
I push for it
the only way to stop a shooter who is
active on campus is to have other people
who are armed the only way to stop it's
not a cliche the only way to stop a bad
guy with the gun is a good guy with the
gun and in addition to that there's the
entire idea of a gun-free gun-free zone
it is utterly stupid yeah it is just
completely stupid all it's doing is
enticing a target saying look you go
here so here's here's what's the school
the average response time from police
station to a school nationally it's 15
minutes the average time of school
shooting happens is five minutes that
means the shooter has 15 minutes to do
with whatever he wants if the school is
a gun-free zone so here's what I'm
saying at least allow teachers who have
gone to the proper training you know
ex-military X law enforcement to be
armed because what that does is it sends
not only a message as a deterrent to a
shooter that says look this school is
armed if you get in here your brains are
gonna be blown out it also says that
that the school is in a gun-free in the
school is no longer a gun-free zone so
I'm I'm with you partly on that so what
I would maybe and maybe you can explain
this a little bit further so I don't
know that I want guns in those
classrooms even if
it's so here's the license here's the
nothing fit there are 25 states where
teachers can be armed in our armed in
schools mhm and all the hypotheticals
that are pronounced it's like you know
what if a teacher shoots a student when
there's another like like what if
there's a school shooter and a teacher
gets shot and there's a gun on the floor
what does a student do it's these
hypotheticals don't happen 25 states
where teachers already armed and it
works so why not just have them have
security guards at specific dimensions
here's the thing I'm all for having
security guards this entire issue is how
do we best manage our funds and secure
our schools the thing with law
enforcement officers is that they cost a
lot of money and impoverished schools
already need that funding for materials
and in addition it does not take a lot
of training and a lot of money to have a
teacher to be armed and this has already
been proven to work in an edition when
you have teachers who are armed the
shooter doesn't know who it is if you if
it's a law enforcement officer you can
clearly see who it is so if you've one
resource officer school resource officer
who's armed the shooter comes and takes
out the school resource officer and then
they're free to do whatever yeah but
it's simply so here's the thing simply
giving teachers to have the opportunity
has a massive effect because it's up to
their own will to do so they have to go
through training and they have to it's a
concealed carry so nobody knows they
have them so as you said before you like
facts and logic okay yeah strictly facts
don't care about your feelings all right
I got you that that that works when when
you've engaged some of your friends and
other students about these ideas I mean
everyone watching this at this point
knows that so much of what's coming out
of the modern left is about feelings and
all the other things do you have a sense
that they understand that young people
at least the ones you're talking to
understand like what rights are what why
why we should care about these things
why free speech matters why the Second
Amendment matters and things of that
nature so or does it all just sound good
to them and there's a that's pretty much
it it makes them feel good you know what
they push and makes them feel good by
their emotions that makes sense so
here's the thing I am very scared of
lowering the age for people to vote to
be 15 like that scares me because the
kids that I know who are
tene know absolutely nothing about
politics I think I know like the kids
from a March for our lives better than I
think I know their own arguments better
than they know their own arguments the
guy can argue for them better than they
can do so I strictly use facts only so
when I make an argument with them I
can't really know what they're gonna do
next so here's how I'll give you like a
10 minute or 5 minute Rica tour
basically how I promise the Second
Amendment argument in America we have
the right to bear arms in DC vs. Heller
that right ruled that an individual's
right to arms doesn't mean the militia
the militia Clause is different from the
individual right to bear arms that means
that you personally have the right to
arm yourself okay there are about 270
million guns in United States 15 million
those are ar-15s so we look at the gun
sets or 33 thousand annual gun deaths
sixty-six percent so two-thirds are
suicide so it leaves us with 11,000 gun
deaths so we have so in addition in put
in parentheses there's a different scene
a homicide and a murder
so homicide is just a killing a murder
is an unlawful killing and gun stats a
lot of them like to perverse this into
skew statistics so three percent of all
gun deaths are with rifles okay and in
that three percent 68 percent of those
are suicide so 1% of all gun that's
their actual murders or actually sorry
yeah are actually murders with rifles 80
percent of all gun crime related
activity is with illegal firearms most
schools most shootings are with pistols
so so March for lives has five bullet
points one of them is like I don't talk
about I like to talk about the CDC and
we should allow the CDC to do research
the issue with that is the CDC has
already proven to skew of statistics and
and to not actually provide good
research but what research is it that
they want so the CDC used to be able to
do research on undone violence
prevention and just figure out what's
going on but it's been proven time and
time again that they screw their
statistics so the throne was like no
we're not allowing you to portray a
false myth so a myth so basically they
stopped funding the next thing is that
they want high-capacity magazines there
is no distinction there there is no
difference
that shows that high-capacity magazines
whatever that means you can do more
damage is simply having more like clips
just having smaller just having larger
clips but less of them there's no
distinction that it actually does more
damage the next thing that they want to
do is ban semi-auto rifles as I've said
before only three percent of all gun
deaths are with rifles so it banning
them does absolutely nothing addressing
the issue in lowering gun violence is
making sure that we have Oh making sure
that we have more people who are armed
because there's a direct correlation not
causation but correlation that when we
increase farm ownership and concealed
carry permits in addition violent crime
goes down so the next thing they like to
propose is what about Great Britain and
Australia
so I'm Great Britain there was a there
was a ban on guns it immune ly after
violent crime spiked in addition you
have armed robberies increased so
violent crime increased immediately
after and burglaries in Great Britain
sixty percent of them occur when the
individuals at home versus 30 percent of
the US so burglars have admitted that
they do this because they know that the
person will have like their purse or
whatever and they won't they'll be
unarmed so violent crime spiked the next
thing is they say hey Kyle what about
the Australian gun by program so already
in Australia when the program was
initiated there was already statistical
zero for you know gun death and it's
public mass public school shootings so
in addition when the buyback gets
implemented there already were like
there are millions millions less guns in
Australia than there were now so the gun
buyback grows in only one third of guns
get taken and when we saw immediately
after the buyback was that violent crime
spiked so here's just the basic argument
there has not been one single occurrence
where gun control gets passed and and
and gun deaths no sorry gun homicides
actually decreases at faster rate in
Australia the gun the homicide rate was
already decreasing at a really good rate
it gets passed the gun control and the
rate stalls so it actually hurt by an
addition immediately after it was passed
the violent crime rates go up and the
national trend was going down so the gun
buyback program was completely
ineffective did absolutely nothing and
then it failed on such a huge level in
Australia that implementing it in the US
with George
70 million guns simply won't work
[Music]